he is an NBA champion and also 17
seasons in the National Basketball
Association and also known by two names
in that journey no malice my life in
basketball or how a kid from
Queensbridge survived the streets the
brawls and himself to become an NBA
champion the author of said book Metta
World Peace right here on the Rich Eisen
show good to see you it's good to be
here
it's good to be here with you and that
see even though Mike's my man yeah it's
okay oh good I'm glad I'm glad you are
back here and I'm looking at the
photographs in the back I see you
holding up the Larry O'Brien trophy with
the cigar yes I see you dunking a
basketball in a Pacers uniform yeah I
see you with an Artest uniform from the
Sacramento Kings days absolutely and I
see you with Barack Obama yeah that was
brief though I wasn't really what Barack
Obama what do you mean because he I mean
he was there you know and I was like hey
how you doing and you know he's the
president so you can't get up and give
him a hug last a little too much do you
do look a little chummy though lays his
arms on your shoulder right there he did
he also invited me to the White House to
play a game and that didn't happen but
it's okay
you mean the invitation was didn't come
or I didn't get it I was supposed to go
to my house and play some basketball
I was waiting for this invitation and
were you Metta World Peace at that
pointer I was I was met at that time man
I changed my name cuz I mean the guy
wanted Nobel Peace Prize you'd think
that that it's having somebody with the
last name maybe I wasn't as important as
Kobe and LeBron and weight is fine only
only the best defensive wing to play the
game but it's okay I got it it's okay I
have it so how did a kid from
Queensbridge survive the streets the
brawls and himself to become an NBA
champion you know just some support a
lot of support thank you for everybody
who's helping me out throughout my
career I remember 8th grade Intermediate
School is a Queens got chased out to
school by some beef my older brother had
we looked alike have fight about 10 kids
then I weights like 5 p.m. and so
everybody's gone and never go back to
that school and I got a scholarship cuz
his guys let me play basketball then he
gave me a scholarship to a
LaSalle Academy mmm for years Christian
Brothers school
you know and that's one of the ways and
I mean I was able to go to a Christian
brother school for four years and then
st. John's came in Saint John's Catholic
school was it Louie Carnesecca
I'm Fran Fraschilla and for Sheila came
Alex Evans okay Ron Rutledge you know
they had a great great staff and then I
went to my job is to next year
and javis Junior Mike Jarvis I forgot
about it
my job is love them what st. John's yeah
okay and then interesting title no
malice we all know we why did you choose
that well I didn't want that okay I
don't mind talking about the bra no more
I'm kind of over it the fair mmm then
I'm like mouse um I don't feel like
going down this road man but you're
writing a book yeah you're writing a
book but I don't really care about
selling books you know I'm like I rather
sell no books and have that title mm-hmm
but you know Ryan Dempsey was like it'd
be pretty cool and I was worried about
how people would think about it and I
don't care about what people think about
me much Dempsey being your co right
you're gonna be yes okay and then
triumph you know we all came up with the
title pretty much we all agreed on it
but I was very worried about that title
but you know I guess it's a book and I
guess you know people want that type of
title well I mean it definitely is well
I could see how you'd want to put that
behind you but I mean in a book
everything is kind of laid bare right
now what do you what do you mention
about it in this book I mentioned about
I talked about the bet you know people
don't understand
although my career was going this way
but emotionally I was going down in 2004
I was averaging 18 points a year before
and then I was trying to sixth in voting
for MVP and I got Defensive Player of
the Year
so my goal was to come back that yeah
get MVP you know so I was on I was on
target and I and we had the most wins in
the regular season Jermaine O'Neal all
those guys
so that season I was still going crazy
emotionally I was still going the
opposite directions but the guy who
threw a cup of berry me John Green who
was a friend of mine now it was a $50
bet so when a guy raises him and I and I
hate on a small table I thought he hit
me how my there's no reason for anybody
to be raising their hands and cheering
because the game is not going on
something okay you hit me
I went in that direction and then John
Green was like he saw me running he kind
of skinned it up like oh I hope Metta
don't all Ryan doesn't think it's me
right so um so the guy raised his hand
because he old John Green $50 that he
could hit me so they was just drunk
having fun which everybody does that
does silly things but you know it cost
me it cost me tons and tons of millions
of dollars but you're friends with the
guy who who hit you with the beer
absolutely this is reason why this is
reason why I reached out to him because
I didn't I don't like to hold grudges
you know and then also and this life is
bigger than getting hit with a cup of
beer begins to spin they're losing tens
and tens of millions of dollars and um
you know life is bigger than that you
understand and things happen you know
and we move on how did you read how did
you find him how did you find well when
I first got suspend from the parole I
thought everybody hated me I was still
young you know in my own mind I had like
three full personalities at that age or
hearing things right now I was just
going crazy at that age and then I said
you know I need to get rid of this I
need to feel better by myself so I
reached out to on Twitter I said hey if
anybody could find this picture I'll
take you to lunch I didn't put the name
because it was John Green and I didn't
want people to think Ron Artest to reach
out to John Green it's not a fight you
know so I'll put the picture up and I'm
this guy I said I know who that is
that's John Green he found them for me
he gave me his number I called the
number from direct message and it said
uh this number has been changed and then
it gives you the right number right so
and then I'm so I don't make no sense
why he did that back in the days right
it's stupid or something I called I
called the number I said hey this is Ron
can I speak to John his wife answers and
she says get the F out of here right yes
he says stop playing games I said no I'm
serious this is Ron
hmm and then she said hey John Ron's on
the phone right like we are friends it's
the funniest story I wish he could have
filmed it John answers the phone and
this is the this is the guy who threw
the cup at me I can see why he's crazy
he answers the phone and says hey Ron
what's up
like he knows me you understand what
whoo hey Ron what's up how you doing
very sorry you
said right away check to see if it was
me like he just knew was me III would
have I would I would have paid anything
you hear that cop it was amazing it was
he said you know I'm sorry about what
happened then he told me the story about
the bed you know which is like wild like
it made me feel so much better about
that situation you know cuz it was no
way out that situation no way from no
way he felt better to know that he made
a bet that he could hit you with the
beer yeah because everybody kept for one
they blamed me for something that was on
TV and it wasn't my fault I didn't start
this thing but they say I did right okay
cool and into it to find out who was a
bit you understand
mm-hmm well look I know you don't want
us have no malice in the title but I
mean that's an incredible story that's a
great way to get people to John to check
out the rest of this book new no malice
my life in basketball how a kid from
Queensbridge survived the streets the
brawls and himself to become an NBA
champion did he ever get the 50 bucks
I'm gonna ask him that generator follow
up question on that all right I want to
take a break come back ask you what what
youth who you think is gonna win the NBA
Finals yeah or the Final Four absolutely
and then we have culled some some Metta
World Peace facts okay true or false
that we're gonna ask my two guys over
there to say to see who knows more about
you and you will confirm whether these
are true meadow or false Metta let's do
it that's next year on the Rich Eisen
show
okay Metta World Peace no malice my life
and basketball check it out where books
are sold
what do you think of a Final Four here
who do you thinks gonna wind up winning
the NBA championship Metta World Peace
well well LeBron is my favorite player
and my kid loves them and we think he's
great but I feel like the Warriors are
gonna win you know I think Kevin Durant
needs a second reign to stop being in
that same conversation is Kobe LeBron
and Jordan Sunday must-win so they must
win in that they must win you don't
think Houston's gonna knock him out no I
can't see he said be in these guys even
though they're number one why is that I
mean the reason is because the way the
Warriors moved the ball their whole team
is back also so but I mean hard moves a
ball hard in this year more than ever
and I'm Chris Paul was there to help
move the ball and he's playing off the
wall a fella capela could create some
matchup problems for Golden State a
little bit they can they can I think
this is their first year at playing as
well right because I still don't know
how good the Warriors would have been
they were hurt now they're back so I'm
thinking that they're just gonna repeat
you know and win the title so you think
the it's gonna be Cavs versus Warriors
again fourth year in a row and the
Warriors take it down I think so okay so
we have cold Metta World Peace we have
called some some Metta World Peace facts
okay
from from your book here and just from
life in general and we'd like to play a
game with Chris Brockman and Mike Dell
to foe over there okay where I will read
out the facts they will guess whether
it's true Metta or false Metta and then
you will confirm okay here we go
Rich Eisen show presents real meta you
are fake okay very good
is there any music for music here we go
very good alright first uh fat is true
during my rookie season with the Chicago
Bulls I applied for a job at sirki
Circuit City true meta or fake meta I've
heard this story I believe that's true
Mike oh I'm going with him true the true
story that's a true story that's a true
story get the job at Circuit City I did
get the job I got the job I got my
discount I was trying to stay out of
trouble okay and I needed a job did you
use a discount oh yeah I got so much
what was the job was it like basic
stereos or something you come in there
and yeah I was gonna start the probably
but you come in there and I say hey are
you doing some people do I was still
yeah I wasn't a superstar here we go
next act I wore number 37 for the Lakers
because Michael Jackson's album Thriller
was number one on the Billboard charts
for 37 Canseco
no way no way pick that up that is 100%
true that's true come back with the
Wizards I broke two of Michael Jordan's
ribs in a pickup game and delayed his
comeback by three months I was so upset
about it I didn't leave my house for
days true metal or fake meta I think
that's true I'm saying true that's true
I love Michael Jordan my one of my blood
and probably my favorite play he broke
his ribs but it was on accident it was a
summertime pickup game and it was a
intense game next one my official name
changed to Metta World Peace was delayed
for a month because of outstanding
traffic tickets true Metta fake Metta
Mike dill to faux that's false
Chris fake Metta I don't think you're
driving yourself around I'll save false
you sure that's not true 2010 an art
show honoring me was held in Toronto
Canada entitled lovable badass true meta
fake meta a false true that's true
just said hey for what you know and they
just have all this art me that could
have been a great title for your book
instead of no malice oh yeah
next one next one alright last one last
one in 2010 I was cited for driving a
race car with an expired registration
down a city street reaction I would say
true I gotta go true to that's true it
was an Indy 500 car which one what city
you know so a street-legal you had an
expired registration was the issue what
happened was the officer was like what
is this that's why they pulled me over
like you know it was real like this and
hitting the gas in my little pinky toes
fantastic no malice my life and
basketball or how a kid from
Queensbridge survived the streets the
brawls and himself to become an NBA
champion fun times with you sir
absolutely thanks for coming York so
this book is available where books are
sold everywhere and then grid' ello com2
get involved with your youth program out
here in los angeles correct absolutely
fleet please support it and you can see
a lot of great things but it's been
going well thank you okay and it's GRA
de ello dot-com
to check all that out lovable badass
Metta World Peace good to see you here
so to be a so our number three we've got
Brian Scalabrine calling in to set up
the brain you do huh he's a really good
talented he's good he's a he's a level
badass too and the white Mamba he's
doing so I love talking to him by the
way you know somebody messed with my
Wikipedia called you that right for
about a week
somebody said Rich Eisen aka white Mamba
so the two white momma's will have a
conversation next on the Rich Eisen show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience